Hello!
Hi!
Reese Witherspoon:
When we got together, a long
time ago, we were talking about how country music
should stop limiting people and
start opening doors.
Kacey Musgraves:
It’s music brought over from all
over the world.
The bluegrass, the folk, the
gospel.
Kacey Musgraves:
There’s so many threads woven
through country music.
♪♪
Reese Witherspoon:
This is “My Kind Of Country”
A music competition that travels
the globe to break the next country music star.
♪♪
Reese Witherspoon:
We’re partnering with three
trail-blazing, country musicians,
Jimmie Allen:
It took me eleven years to get a record deal.
I lived in my car.
Mickey Guyton:
I was the first black female
solo artist
Mickey Guyton:
to earn a Grammy Nomination in a
Country category.
Orville Peck:
My mask allows me to be more
vulnerable
and share my perspective as a
gay country artist.
Reese Witherspoon:
They are gonna search the world
for musicians and invite them to Nashville.
Oh my gosh!
Ultimately, there will be one
person who wins a life-changing
prize from Apple Music.
♪♪
This is the reason why you let
your kids follow their dreams.
♪♪
Got my bag packed here!
Nashville, I’m coming.
♪♪
Welcome to Nashville!
Mickey Guyton:
They say country music is three
chords and the truth.
It’s singing about life and your
life story.
♪♪
I don’t feel like I can express
myself in English so I sing it
in Spanish.
♪♪
I struggle with my own inner
voice a little bit but when I
get to sing I feel totally whole.
(Cheering)
That was so sincere and
beautiful and that is country
music.
♪♪
There’s just so much potential
for something I don’t think
anybody’s ever seen before in country music.
♪♪
The people that I love in
country music, they don’t look
like me.
Camille:
I’m ready to show people
what they’ve been missing.
♪♪